okay for those joining us we are doing a
bit of work from language design here
we are talking about error handling and
we have
uh an elaborate set of proposals which i
have not seen yet
um
and just let's take a look at the
motivation and current problems
um
okay exceptions are widely used but
completely non-standardized
okay that's interesting but what do you
mean by an exception you mean something
that just stops execution dead in its
tracks
essentially something based on throw and
catch
okay but but in
confirming clothes is or is not thought
of as an exception
if you give it a tag it is kind of an
exception but that's not really
something we're promoting
so
close and confirm are more similar to
like
optionals in some languages because you
don't throw them across
uh function boundaries
i see
i see that so they're they're enclosed
within so the point of an exception is
something went horribly wrong and you're
basically trying to exit to the top
level is that correct
pretty much yeah
yes but i would like to point out that
exceptions are not necessarily error
conditions i mean there are things like
a file
uh when a file ends then you have a
choice of either returning something and
then dragging along that if statement or
you can generate an exception and handle
it somewhere more appropriate so it is a
it is a proper way of programming and
not necessarily tied to something going
wrong
okay
to put it differently exceptions are
typically used whenever you need some
non-local
transform transfer of control flow
uh and while it's not usually wise to
use them in that capacity all the time
and usually it's associated with errors
but
you can you can use them in a variety of
other situations as well
robert so what you're saying is enclosed
confirm
is something which is essentially a
functional programming construct
that is a nested essentially lexical you
know collections of functions whereas
what you're interested in here is
something that just sort of gets out of
whatever
complicated stack of code you might be
in and you don't have to and there's
nothing sort of lexically defined in
there is that is that roughly right or
am i wrong
yeah i mean i think but part of it is
also that i mean
in smaller pieces of code well
right i mean basically one of the
another way to think about it is it's a
question of whether the errors are
propagated by default or when you ask
them to be so then close and confirm if
a function returns an error you have to
explicitly wrap confirm around it again
to propagate it to the next level so you
sort of have to ask for errors to be
propagated which is usually what you
want well i think it's what you want in
small projects as well and maybe even
some larger ones but but if you have
really big projects and lots of very
deep recursion and you don't know you
know which functions are returning uh
good return failures and so on then it's
a lot safer for things to propagate
errors by default you know which is what
exceptions kind of do
okay fine
okay so should i
um
right i mean i had been intending to
kind of do the walkthrough of this
notebook um
but please should do you want to share
and do it i'm all set up to share yeah
okay fine go for it
right so
uh
i mean
as you as you framed i mean the meetings
we're talking about error handling um
we're kind of talking about i like to
think about what we're talking about
kind of three different phases
um so one thing we've been focusing on i
mean let me open this up
um is
i mean some of the constraints we're
working with are we want to avoid
kind of creating uh divergence between
uh confirming closed type you know
failure propagation and exception type
failure propagation um and one of the
things i want to highlight is a lot of a
lot of proposals that have gone on in
the past about exceptions generally
involve some kind of exception object um
and we've tried to focus a bit more
narrowly on what are the
kind of minimal improvements we can make
to an existing form like failure to
accomplish a lot of the same uh goals
that we have without adding a new form
to the system and in particular we don't
want things
that
are not specific to the way that the
error is propagated
to be present in kind of the design so
so basically
whether the error is thrown or whether
it is returned or whether it is
propagated using confirm and close
shouldn't really change what's in the
error or what's in the failure
um
so obviously we're going to talk a bit
about failure itself and some things we
want to do to
hopefully make improvements to failure
and then we're going to talk a bit about
uh improvements to exceptions in general
um
so
you know
there's kind of phases for this um first
is improvement specifically to failure
these would be things that have nothing
to do with exceptions and would be
general improvements uh for projects
with you know that are not using
exceptions or for projects that are
using exceptions um so a basic one is uh
building up infrastructure for
uh
making stack traces a bit uh easier to
capture and a bit easier to display and
um a bit easier to kind of compute with
um now leonid will have i think he may
have an example of this later
but i'm just going to kind of give an
illustrative overview of this so a
simple thing would be is you want to add
a stack trace field as a convention to
failure objects so obviously failure
objects can contain any kind of metadata
we want to define a form that could be
kind of a conventional thing that goes
in that stack trace field
um
this is a kind of a side point but we
wanted to do some changes to the the
formatting of failure because it's not
ideal in all circumstances especially
when you have larger richer failures
then the other thing we want to do is
kind of
improve the the tagging
of failures right now if you look at the
documentation for failure
it
the tag of a failure the thing that
gives its identity is basically just a
string and for a number of reasons we
want to kind of
make that form a little bit more general
um one specific reason is that
as i mentioned up here a lot of projects
have their own
rays and catch functions and one of the
underlying uh structural reasons for
that is that um we have uh throw and
catch and we have a two argument form of
throw and catch and the two argument
form of thrown catch has this tag
argument uh you can actually have a look
at that
uh
do this down here um
so two argument form of throw has a tag
and two argument form of catch has a tag
and these are meant to kind of scope or
as a pattern sorry that matches
you know a set of tags um and these are
meant to provide some some level of
scoping to to the thing that gets thrown
um
and a common convention and one of the
reasons that these these paired
functions pop up in a lot of internal
projects is that people want to make
that tag some unique key that's specific
to their project so they can be
confident that the exceptions they're
throwing are only getting
caught by uh like they're caught by
their own code
and we want to add uh you know a similar
ability to filter for failures that are
generated by by you know you know a
given code base
um i mean the thing about the two
argument form of throw and catch is that
it's it's integral to how that error is
interpreted but it's not directly
computable it's not part of the thing
that's thrown which makes our exceptions
a little bit different than than
exceptions you find in a lot of other
languages and it also makes it a bit
harder to kind of programmatically
decide
uh based on the content of the thing
that is thrown whether you want to catch
it in one location or another
so our concretely what we want to do is
add support for using symbols as tags
and potentially using kind of
collections of symbols a list of symbols
and i'll talk a bit a little bit more in
phase two about that
um
but that's the basic idea we want to
make that tag field richer so we can
have richer identity for failures
um
and
one of the functions we're talking about
adding maybe to support stack traces and
tags
is a new create failure function which
would automatically uh add in that stack
trace field based on some kind of global
configuration
and one reason to do that is that if you
have a large project you know where
you're creating failures all over the
place most of the time you don't want
those fields to those failures to
include stack traces because stack
prices are kind of
a thing that the programmer might want
to look at but as a user of a piece of
functionality if you get a stack trace
with a whole bunch of internal function
names that's hopeless you know your that
doesn't really help you figure out what
went wrong
um but we want to make it possible for
for people to write code that uses
failures in a way that they can later in
specific situations opt into having
those failures include stack traces so
we're thinking about something like a
dollar capture back traces you know
system level variable as an example
that would change the behavior of create
failure to either include or not include
that stack trace field automatically
and obviously that behavior would be
would be overrideable with a with a
local option
usually a create function
is creating some kind of global thing
that
is you know in some global table but
this is not what this is doing this is
creating this is
making a specifically templated form of
failure object is that correct
uh that's correct and the name might not
be i might not be perfect probably make
failure or something like that would be
a better name but
yeah actually i think i started with
make failure and then create yeah anyway
all right okay we do have things like
create data structure and create
compiler environment
but yeah yeah well okay whatever let's
not solve that problem right now
um but that's we want to form a function
of this form that does the conditional
stack trace uh you know addition and
also does some additional operations on
that tag that we talked about
um
so
hold on a second i mean so so
a failure object usually
failure does not usually evaluate
usually it just sits there as a as a you
know inert symbolic thing
yeah you mean the constructor for
failure yes
yes
so you're proposing that at construction
time
that it might have pieces that it
captures at construction time
uh
ads not captures but yeah it would be
something the constructor could have
additional logic like whether to add
this stack trace field or not
okay fine but i mean as a the basic
point is in this block of code
for example or maybe globally but i
think it'd be better in a block of code
that sort of
that
all failure objects because i can
imagine a situation where
most of the time you don't want to
capture the stack trace and just
generally make a big mess but if you're
in a debugging mode you do want that to
happen
exactly we could have a dollar you know
stack traces or something which was true
yeah or we could just have a function a
wrapper that says you know um stack
traceify and then some big block of code
and that would do the same thing i mean
it would be a a similarly dynamic
set thing which then would cause all the
failure objects that are created in that
you know because i to me it seems like
you're either it's more a question of
what is the runtime environment than
what is you know one block of code wants
to have stack traces another block code
doesn't it's more i'm either running it
in a mode where i want that stuff or i'm
running it in a mode where i don't want
that stuff seems to me yeah so that
that's exactly correct yeah i mean this
was not meant to be something you hard
code into your project but you know
something you put at the top level when
you the programmer are trying to debug
it
right so capture stack traces as a
wrapper seems like a nice idea and then
then okay so then then every failure
object could i i could certainly
see
you know uses where inside your project
you always want to capture the stat
trace because you know you're going to
handle that and return something nicer
to the user
yeah
i mean
what you always do but that's certainly
something you might want to do
yeah we could even imagine the users uh
may want to do that if they want to
submit some bug report with a stack
trace
which might simplify uh work on our side
right
yes but i mean but my point is
that once this thing is in capture stack
trace mode
every
um you know every failure object created
doesn't need a separate create failure
wrapper just everything no no no no no
no this has to be a wrapper function
we'll explain below there are other
reasons to have it okay all right i'm
not convinced yet but just okay i get
the point there is a way of getting
inside a failure object there is a
standardized collection of things one
might add like stack traces
yeah
um
now the other thing that we've been
talking about doing in this create
failure and why we need a function as
opposed to you know just using failure
um is this concept of tag expansion so
the first step in adding richer identity
to failures is supporting symbols not
just strings in that failure tag
the second step and this is something
that comes into play in larger projects
where you have kind of more complicated
relationships between errors
um
is that you want kind of a you know a
light subclassing mechanism to be able
to say that one type of error is kind of
a you know represent is one element of a
class of errors
um and a simple example
in this illustrative examples notebook
is a file not found error is also a file
error and an io error um and this is
slightly pseudo code but this is roughly
what this might look like is if you do
create failure of this thing you get a
failure out that that kind of says what
the primary error is but then also says
what the other
classes of error that this thing fits
into are
and this is
the reason you want this is that you
often have again in larger projects
a lot more
some kind of outer handler you know at
the top level of your code where the
exception reaches up to the you know
whatever your public function is you
have some big thing that handles all the
failures that your code can produce and
so you want to kind of match over what
each kind of failure
that came out of your code was
um
okay
right so i mean look just to make a
general comment about all of this okay i
think one way to think about this is
you know people write code intending it
to follow a particular path
where most of the time
it will you know do what they think it
will do but sometimes it doesn't and
sometimes it hits a guard rail
and you know spins out of control
and i think one of the issues is
is there a way to
you know is there a way to basically
bucket the ways that it might spin out
of control so that they can be bulk
handled because we're not going to
handle every single code path of every
single different way or you don't want
to have to you want to be able to
automate handling a whole collection of
different ways it could spin out of
control
and that's exactly what this system is
supposed to do that we are discussing
right and so one of the things we've
talked about and i like this comment
from from connor about you know this
point about intersecting tagging because
one of the issues is you know we've
tried this even from version one
of kind of identifying from our messages
for example what kind of you know is
this message a critical failure or is it
you know a oh you could ignore it
failure you know the the
numerix numerics fail to converge error
is not a critical error if you're just
trying to lay out some graphic it is a
critical error if you're trying to you
know launch some spacecraft or something
right so
yeah one person's you know depending on
the use case and it is the case that
there are plenty of exploratory analysis
cases where even
getting out you know you've got a
thousand pieces of data you're going to
get out and seven of them have failures
in them you still want the other ones to
come out you don't want it to say oh
there's ones that are failures i'm going
to shut everything down
yeah
and and to make that concrete i mean i
have these
look at these examples these are
slightly pseudo code again but the idea
is that uh in in this phase two section
we're actually talking about
improvements to exceptions themselves um
we have this concept of a handle
function now this is analogous to catch
but it differs in in some fundamental
ways the basic idea is that it
it allows you to sort of match over the
failures that get thrown
so this is how you would actually
implement you know handling a file not
found error you know differently from a
general i o error
and this is how you would implement what
you were talking about where you might
have
you know something that i didn't expect
when happened but it's a case it's class
of the the very generic i o error type
so i can print some generic thing saying
that hey an io error occurred um and if
you want to i mean you could have we
have this kind of concept of
so you know most people who use software
when they see the thing unknown error
occurred
they're like
what the heck happened here
you know
it's it's anyway that's a horrible wimp
out um
right well sometimes it's the best can
you do you can do if you're not uh
well i understand that but so my
question would be of all the messages
and i don't know how many thousands
there are that are associated with
built-in functions right now are you
imagining that we bucket those messages
to be
uh to have tags
that are effectively like
um
you know that that that map into this
this era system
so there isn't currently any specific
proposal like to turn messages in
directly into tags um
one of the
places that this handle function came
out of and roman is kind of the
originator of this handle design that
we've kind of retrofitted it to this
proposal um
is that it kind of serves as a
combination of like check and catch
and check abort and that you could
do you know that you could do something
like i'm gonna kind of
make this up but you could do something
like
uh to catch messages or to handle
messages with this form
um
and that might be a way that we have a
single construct that can handle every
type of thing that can go wrong in the
system um
in in one unified yeah i understand but
the problem is
these look one of the issues is
you're doing your rocket launch
you want to make sure there's nothing
you know no
message generated that was a numerics
fail to converge whatever else
you're doing your user interface layout
you want to make sure that there can be
no pink boxes
right different kinds of things that you
want to make sure of
um and you know that was one of the
original
issues here was sort of making buckets
of those types of things
um
but it's also not just buckets it's a
hierarchy
which i think is also useful i mean well
one of the other reasons why the
hierarchy aspect i think is very
important is that i think that you know
the solution to the
right you know the problem with throwing
catch again is that you need to have
project specific tags in order for you
know there not to be cross you know
cross uh
package uh catches and throws that that
interact with each other and so part of
the solution here is that you know you
can have
it it wouldn't be hard to sort of
introduce basically an error class which
is a lot like a tag for your specific
project
but it's sort of it's much more
ergonomical to have you know
it's much more
with this interface it's much nicer to
do that than it is to do with thrown
catch right now
and and regarding the point about
classifying messages i mean i i i spec
this out kind of on a whim but um we
could imagine having something like i
was thinking like a logic error type you
know super class so if you're if you
have a failure in your code that
represents like i said you know
something that you the programmer didn't
anticipate occurred so it's kind of a
fatal error if that happens during your
rocket launch something is terribly
wrong um and you might have us you know
the very outer edges of your code you
might have a handler for these these
kind of very high level error types um
where you just want to bail and give up
as quickly as possible because if this
happens yeah you're
you're really in unknown territory um
and we could imagine something like
classifying built-in messages into you
know things like these classes though i
think i think the problem is and the
problem that i think previous efforts to
classify these messages have failed is
that it's very context dependent often
why a message gets generated and what
that actually means
um
so it's it's not easy to make a
definitive mapping of something like
general rxc to a specific error
tag
um right but maybe the trick is just to
give the tags
uh or these error classes to give them
less presumptuous names
yeah
but but there is also this problem that
connor mentioned indeed because most of
the time people in this specific project
will introduce their own customer types
and so there will be it will be them who
will be decided deciding which uh to
which more general classes these
specific errors belong
while here if we try to classify
messages uniformly then we are kind of
trying to make old decisions for all the
kind of different situations for people
and
that's where the problem really lies
there's also of course a question of how
much effort we should put into our into
maintaining our error messages or
whether we shouldn't gradually move from
error messages to failure objects
wherever we can because
no we don't want to do that we don't
want to do that there are plenty of
error messages that are just side
commentary we don't want to return a
failure object whenever you know
whenever the numerical scheme is not
converging as quickly as we thought we
don't want to return a failure object
i mean
there are
at the moment there are still a lot of
cases where things return unevaluated
and that unevaluated thing that just
explodes in all of the well that's
correct that that's
okay look
there are on about cases where it
returns unevaluated where there are
serious possibilities that people might
overwrite the unevaluated thing and want
to do something with it
there are other cases where it returns
unevaluated only because
35 years ago that was the best
convention we could that was you know we
had the idea that more people would
redefine those things like you know
the
the inverse of a you know let's say the
inverse of a
a singular matrix
okay that returns unevaluated
now we could return a failure object but
i don't think that would be the right
thing to do
in that case i think but i'm thinking
more of things like wrong number of
arguments right i mean there's
absolutely nothing you can do with that
that's not correct that's just not
correct i mean well there's i think
there's also things like net train i
think it's less about the the the
how incorrect your usage is it's more
about the domain i mean if you're doing
sort of symbolic mathy stuff then it's
very commonly unevaluated things but if
you're doing net train
there's really no world in which an
unevaluated you know a net train is ever
going to end up evaluating successfully
yeah
right and this is this is a general
problem we have where that in a lot of
places where the semantics requires some
more aggressive error handling
we still have to rely on messages and
the real problem with that there are a
few problems with messages which make
them as an ex as an error handling
mechanism pretty poor compared to
exceptions and that's why i think roman
mentioned this problem that in those
places where
exceptions or other more aggressive
error handling methods are more
suitable we really would like to switch
to those well i understand that but you
also this is the why i mentioned this
point
about for a rocket launch you want the
numerix error to be fatal
right right
four for a layout on the screen
you just don't care
right right well the the obvious
solution is just just you know
if you wanted to have some transition
thing i mean if we're forgetting about
backwards compatibility and stuff like
that right then what you'd want is you
want it so things still throw messages
but they also raise exceptions and if
you don't handle the exceptions then
nothing happens you know like it's just
it just runs like normal or if you do
ask to catch them then then it will
start i think that's sensible yes i
think that's a good a decent idea i mean
i think that that yes that's a
reasonable idea that we use the fact
that we've got thousands of messages in
the system
which indicate various kinds of error
conditions
you know the challenge and we've tried
to do this we we tried to do it even
there's even code
that tries to do this in the messages
system that tries to bucket messages for
example we have the off mechanism that's
from 35 years ago for switching off
messages and it has a way of bank
switching off messages
or it tried to have such a way it was
much harder to classify those messages
than one might have thought but i do
like the idea of a multi-tagged
i think we already had that idea
actually like decades ago of being able
to put a given message into multiple tag
bins you mean message groups
yes that's what i mean
is that what yeah
right so certainly message groups need
not be
uh
disjoined right
um
right and they were created for v6 and
then they were never updated
imagine again not how you write this but
something you want to handle a graphics
type message
differently um i like that idea that
christopher about
having a a kind of
maybe you could think of it as like a
default handler that if it if it doesn't
get handled
execution resumes where it was thrown
um that would certainly be unique i
think the wolfram language but it's it's
a nice idea
um i mean you could imagine something
like
you know in the handler definition like
the outer level you know for a message
you could like return the symbol
continue i mean this is maybe weird but
something that would indicate like
we want to make this programmable so
this isn't like in you know special
behavior people could work with this um
and if the handler says continue then
execution just picks up where where it
left off
down deep in the code
um
and you could kind of decide on a per
message and per context basis what you
want to do
um is that implementable yeah that i i
don't think that's implementable how
would you implement something like that
you would need continuation support for
that
yeah
which well presumably the evaluator i
mean it it knows about i mean i find
that maybe it's harder than i think but
like in compiled languages right like
the implementation of the stack trace
mechanism like lib unwind which is kind
of the standard for this
it you register handlers for kind of
exception tags and you can kind of
indicate there's a kind of a really
low level way of indicating basically
return a bit flag saying what you want
to do with that exception whether a
specific handler handles it
i don't know if the kernel uses
something like that but you could
imagine you know the handle function
would register a set of handlers and at
the point that one of these special
messages is issued it would check the
set of registered handlers and see is
there a handler for this type of thing
if so
run it
see what it returns if it doesn't return
something that says if it returns kind
of normally then control flow picks up
you know in the statement after the
handle if it returns the special symbol
that indicates continue where the
message was generated then
the kernel would just keep going where
it started um it wouldn't actually
unwind the stack until it ran the
handler
okay
okay well i i i think we would need you
know people like tom and mark to point
on something okay let's keep going here
so
right so we got slightly off track it's
it's an interesting idea that we should
explore that in future discussions
um
right so we're talking about create
failure we did kind of get into raisin
handle um which is the next thing i was
going to talk about
i mean again raise is analogous to throw
it's argument structure i'm just going
to skip ahead
its argument structure is very similar
to create failure really the only
difference is that create failure
doesn't throw an exception and raise
does
so they take virtually identical
argument structures
and that's really all there is to say
about raise handle is where things get
complicated
but i do want to talk a bit more
specifically about this this tag
expansion idea and what that actually
looks like
um so the basic idea that we have at the
moment about how that would work is that
we have an additional new symbol a new
function called create error type
something like that or register error
type maybe
um and with that you you pass in the
name of the error type you're
registering as a symbol and you pass in
the list of uh super error types
essentially you know the sets of error
types that your sub error type fits into
and additionally there's a three
argument form that kind of lets you
register a validator function something
that gets applied to
any failure object that is created with
this tag um and that that gives you a
little bit of more control over uh
ensuring that an error failure of a
specific tag
actually has a specific form
um
and you know so you want to be able to
validate that if you handle this error
at a higher level it's always going to
have for example the file path metadata
key so you can you know produce that in
a message or something and format with
it
um something like that
um
so that's how you register a new tag
then there's this concept of tag
expansion where these things actually
get get kind of blown up into this form
that you see in the resulting failure
because when you
skip this list for now we'll get back to
that but when you call create failure
right with a specific tag
the thing you get out might be something
like this so if we were to evaluate this
create error type up here that says my
error is a subtype of i o error and then
this idea of using things as symbols or
as heads but anyway never mind that's a
detail
yeah i mean i yeah um it's a detail um
but the basic idea is you call create
failure with the specific error type it
fills in something that looks like this
i mean this is the alternative form i'm
i'm slightly partial to this form where
it's just a list
um
and it fills in the super type and then
there's this kind of general error super
super type that everything is a subclass
of but that's also kind of a detail
um
and you get out if you do all this you
get out of failure that has well okay
this is actually ignore that um but this
is this is the idea this is what you get
out um
and one of the things that i want to
point out here this may be obvious but
we're trying to avoid encoding any kind
of state about the hierarchy of error
types
statically like this failure object has
all the information you need to know
about how to identify this failure there
is no implicit global state about that
my error is a subtype bio error you just
can see that from what's in the failure
itself
because you know these these create
error type calls are building up some
big global state in the kernel of how a
bunch of different failure types relate
to each other and that's fine when kind
of your code is running but if your
program ends and you said earth kernel
quits or whatever you want the failure
you get out to be the stateless thing um
so that's that's why we do this tag
expansion eagerly
uh at the time the failure is created
rather than just depending on that
global state to always exist
um
so that's that's the basic idea with
create failure
okay hold on
i i mean well okay maybe you should show
me the whole picture and then let's come
back into
well we're
we're actually getting pretty close to
the end um i mean there are a lot of
unresolved questions with handle because
it's
it's a much
well and as you can see here there's a
lot of ideas about what it could do
um and
we could talk a little bit about that
but but really i mean i mentioned what
raises i mentioned what
create failure is
hold on hold on go through go through
raise again for a second here sure okay
i mean create failure is basically
creating an enhanced version of a
symbolic failure object
yeah
okay
yeah right is create failure plus throw
it
with possibly additional
stuff
but right
it does it automates the throwing it in
a way that's sort of maximally useful
at least that's the the the idea whether
that's actually true
i suppose can be debated so so this is
then
okay so we've got inc you know
confirming close we've got throw catch
we've got raise handle
these are all different levels of
kind of heavyweightness
of
uh
transferring non-locally transferring
control
i don't think it's so much
heavyweightness but sort of
uh like low level versus high level like
throwing ultimately raise and handle are
just calling throw and catch they're
just right but throwing catcher low
level operations right yeah and
crucially they have no
defined structure raise gives us some
amount of of
dependability that the thing that comes
out
is of a particular form
right yes right so ray's
yes that the thing that is thrown will
be some kind of failure object
yes and it will be self-contained
that's the biggest issue we are trying
to solve and that's why the
standard throw and catch
uh are not very convenient in that
because
the identity they're just showing free
form things right so you don't know what
yeah
yeah and not only that but also the
identity of the throne thing it lives
elsewhere in the tag which is the second
argument while here
the identity lives inside the failure
object
yeah i understand i understand which is
good okay
i understand i mean so so the basic
point here
uh
yeah okay i get it
uh and also this hierarchy of tags that
we are creating allows you to
selectively catch
errors of different generality and
actually uh i don't know if we come to
those examples that i have in a kind of
runnable form i have an example there
where how how you can
uh how you can make a hierarchy
which allows you to easily catch for
instance all the errors within your
package
while they may have internally different
subtypes
okay so you're saying that raise
produces this error
but
you
the choice of whether to handle it
the handler could pass through a raised
error
without handling it if the tags don't
match in some way
exactly that's the whole point of all
this because okay
yeah and then at the at the top level
it you know if the thing ends up at the
level of the rebel unhandled
then what will happen
that's a very big question and that's
something we wanted to discuss in the
phase three maybe conor can also discuss
that now because that's a little bit
going ahead but it's a very important
topic
yeah it probably depends on what the
actual thing that's running it is i mean
if it's running it inside wall from
script or something and it's intending
to be some function that does something
you probably want it to you know just
fail and exit out whereas if you are in
some kind of notebook rebel you
definitely don't want it to quit the
kernel just because
uh some particular
uh exception was unhandled i mean we
already have
currently we have examples of different
behavior i mean if you have an un
called throw then you get some pretty
nasty error message but
if there is an abort inside your program
that is not handled which is the normal
case then it just returns dollar
reporting so that top level handle
should have a little bit of intelligence
inside it to decide maybe with the help
of some tags inside the failure object
whether it is okay to be unhandled or
not
or maybe just
turn the throne failure into a failure
object that is returned
yeah yeah
well but i think i think what should
happen is that the overall
uh you know when you set up your
kernel
in the front end or when you are running
it from
wstp server or or when you're running it
in world from script
probably one of the options there should
be what to do if there's an uncaught
exception
because you want different things to
happen in different cases
yeah i mean that is also very too i mean
that's something i've always struggled
with with parallel parallel kernels
because
there is something at the top level of
that sub kernel but that thing
should in one form or another make it
back to the master kernel and
uh tweak or some appropriate action
there and so at the moment there is no
good way of
kind of handling all that could go wrong
in the in the sub kernels and in the
future there will be and then it will be
much easier to have a clean way of
for example writing
a function that evaluates an expression
and guarantees that whatever happens
inside in c including quit or whatever
it will return with the result of that
evaluation or an indication of whether
there was an error thrown but it will
not escape
yeah but right sometimes you want go
ahead yeah but there is yet another case
which is completely opposite and also
very valuable because right now uh our
public functions are explicitly not
allowed to throw exceptions to the top
level except throw itself and
in some sense exceptions become much
more useful when you allow them to
propagate through the package boundaries
so that's one of the core kind of
questions we really want to decide
whether we in some form because it may
be it may look on the front end in a
pretty nice but uh the whole i mean
whether we allow to
in some cases propagate exceptions to
propagate to the top level or cross the
package boundaries because that would
make them that much more useful
you mean
to have them encapsulated within a
package or to have them able to like
yeah as an example
uh uh like in some cases it may be that
let's say you are building
some functionality on top of some
middleware
and then middleware a sends an exception
and then their next layer is middleware
b which doesn't know how to handle that
exception it would be good if that
middleware b would be allowed to just
pass it through
yeah
yeah yeah yeah right well of course but
that all but that also means that you
know if you directly call a function
which
you know doesn't right if you map with
some package function which isn't a
habit of
you know
throwing an exception that that it
doesn't handle
then you know and you triggered that
exception in your map then you've lost
everything in your map right because
once that's triggered
it completely aborts the computation
yes but that's our responsibility of the
user of the map essentially
but that's i agree it's a tricky
question if you if you pass if you take
some functions as arguments
and those functions
uh are throwing exceptions that's one of
the tricky points where really uh we
need to decide what happens but um
that's one of the complications of
allowing exceptions to propagate yes
so i didn't understand that i'm sorry
could you go through that again
so suppose
you create some package function
you know my wonderful function
and my wonderful function
can
throw an exception now if you
you know
you know
map no map at the cross like range of a
thousand
right right and you know
and nine and 999 generates an
exception
then you get nothing out of your map
because
what do you mean you get nothing out i
see because because then it does it in
particular it runs rays
and rays like throw
just sends through this sends out this
failure object right but in fact the
outer handler says i don't care about
that failure object i'd be fine with you
just you know treating as a pink box or
something right that's the case you're
talking about so you're talking about
inside the inner function
there was a thing i mean so so one way
to handle that
would be since there is execution that
starts off with the handle is called
first because it's the outermost thing
well maybe it isn't i don't know no that
i mean handle presumably
no no there's a there's no handle here
or or if there is a handle it the handle
decided to resolve this issue by just
doing another raise so the exception is
propagating outside of my wonderful
function
that's what leonid is talking about no i
understand that but what you're saying
is at the very outermost level the
handler that it propagates all the way
out to the rebel handler and the rebel
handler says oh actually i don't care
about that error
but you're but it's too late because the
thing already exited the map
exactly
yeah i mean then i mean
then you either you have to wrap handle
around each
call or the question then is if that
exception is fatal then
is it really okay to have no okay hold
on hold on there's a different way to
handle this okay
just as you had a dollar stack trace
capturing thing at the outer level which
was a dynamic variable that seeped into
all of the innards of that computation
so in principle the outer handle if it
was a you know a held function
and you know an outermost evaluation
function
that could set you know the outer handle
that says i don't care
could
set some state that basically says okay
if you've got some inner ray i'm not
sure what is this outer handle you're
talking about
i mean that is the complete input i'm
talking about
what what what connor wrote there
i mean and to frame this i mean imagine
imagine that my wonderful function is
like takes five minutes for each for
each element you know and so you really
don't want to lose your results
but both but sometimes you do in the
rocket launch case you do want to lose
everything
yeah i prefer to okay so what i'm saying
is the decision of whether you lose
everything or not
is taken by the outermost handler the
handler at the rebel level
right or whatever the outermost handler
is
and so what i'm saying is if you define
that outermost handle
to
uh
you know
to be evaluated first before it goes
into its innards so that effectively
dollar pre
at the level of the rebel has a handle
in it and that handle says what things
to care about and what things not to
care about then by the time you're
inside that map
the the thing that does the create
uh
failure
knows oh i'm in an environment where
nobody cares about these kinds of errors
let me not raise that error
still there is a problem with this
approach because it is very general and
it works on all code inside
so in many cases when you try doing that
what ends up happening is that there are
multiple decisions that programmers make
inside the code
and they may not always anticipate that
the global environment has changed
uh so
in practice usually it's safer to have
local rappers like what what corner was
showing uh but he then deleted that
input something like suppress at
uh but the problem with this of course
is that it's an inconvenience for for
the user they'll have to
but i'm sorry i'm sorry i don't quite
understand the issue is
at any given level
you could say this subsystem
is one where so in other words
the innermost handle
is what determines whether a particular
raise
is going to produce a get out of here
response or not
yes but the question is where that
innermost handle has to be
well i assume it's in the evaluation
chain i mean if as opposed to it being
lexical it's something which in the
evaluation chain
uh that gets down to that final map
somewhere there is a handle
that
um
you get what i'm saying
yes
yes i i do i'm just saying that in many
cases
uh such because imagine that you have
code which has like 10 function calls
inside the handle
and in some of them we may want uh
not to throw but in some others
we may actually want to throw
but how do you define that how do you
just how do you describe that and what i
would have thought you do is you say
this is a handle in which i don't care
about class of errors a b and c but i do
care about class of errors x and y
yes but you may inside have function
calls in which in part of which you
really
can kind of don't care and allow things
to
to be thrown or in others you you
actually don't and they may be the same
kind of errors so my point is uh having
a wrapper type handle around some piece
of code might in many cases be
sort of too
uh too wholesale to to really
uh
to really address specifics
look look look
problem with this is the following as i
was saying in the preamble here
the problem is we're trying to this is
automatic coding basically we're trying
to
not have the
programmer have to trace through every
error case and say what to do we're
trying to automate that to some extent
it will not be perfect
but what i'm saying is and i didn't
understand your your comment if they
have more detailed treatment and they
can figure out yes i know that the 200
kinds of errors i could get i'm going to
handle every single one of them in a
precise way we need to give them the
opportunity to do that but most of the
time they won't bother and most of the
time we you know this is essentially an
automatic programming that will do
better than doing nothing but won't
necessarily nail every error case
so
i mean
what am i trying to say i'm trying i
don't understand what's wrong with the
thing i was proposing that is that you
have a series of handles that are passed
through which each dynamically set the
state of the current you know
sort of handling structure
and
so for example one handler could say
uh okay pass i don't care about this
type i mean it's slightly complicated
because you're you're switching on and
off
things that you care about and i don't
know exactly how that works and that
doesn't seem trivial to do you know
there's a there's a who gets to decide
for sure like an inner handler could say
this is a really important message you
know this is a really important error i
want this error to go all the way out to
the rebel but the thing at some level
further out towards the rebel will say
hey wait a minute i don't care about
those kinds of messages so i'm saying so
who wins in that case yeah that's
exactly the problem
because i think that in most cases the
one who should decide
uh whether to propagate an error or not
at least initially is the one who writes
that particular piece of code where
there is getting propagated
and if we try to
second guess that from
global rappers we
may be good in some cases
i want to jump in with a much more
general comment i mean the really zoomed
out picture of what we're doing here is
like the high level problem is right now
it's not as easy as we would like for
people who i are interested in writing
very robust production grade code to do
that in a consistent way right
and
i think it's important to recognize that
when we're talking about error handling
we're talking about you know one of
these extremely fundamental pieces of
infrastructure to people who are
interested in writing robust code
and it i think it's conceivable that we
could imagine a more
you know a
mechanism like you were describing
stephen kind of injects computation at
multiple levels and you know allows very
fine grained control of what happens but
the context is we're talking about
something that needs to be incredibly
reliable you know so that people who are
interested in writing something you say
that
i i no look my claim would be
there is a version of this where
everything is on a hair trigger
anything goes wrong it just exits
okay
that's your case for critical code
yeah but i'm claiming that there are
many many many gradations of that
that go down to this is just exploratory
code
i don't want the thing to blow up the
memory of my computer if it goes in that
corner you know let me protect that but
i don't really care if there are a few
pink boxes on the screen from time to
time
okay i i think there's a you know i
think your hair trigger case
is an important case to cover but it is
not the only case and it will be super
annoying but you know even in
development people are going to want
they're not going to want the hair
trigger case because it's going to be
too much
of like wait a minute you know it's like
it's like okay you're writing a c
program for example okay
and the thing well okay this is a bad
example perhaps but
and you say i want to see what this is
doing and every time you run it it just
crashes
right and you it doesn't get anywhere it
just crashes
it'll be much better and then
that's the good case as far as i'm
concerned because it means they can just
go to the
debugger and and do look at the back
trace yeah i know i know i know i know
so that's why i was saying isn't such a
good example but one could argue that it
would be better to have the thing limp
all the way out i mean the plenty of
times when i'm debugging things we're
having it limp all the way out
and you know five of the values are
correct and then the values six through
nine are wrong
okay or and have a full of symbolic
crowd and error messages and so on
um that's a common form of debugging if
some stuff works other stuff doesn't you
go and look at the stuff that doesn't
work and you don't want it to hair
trigger and go and just say oh it's all
but it's all bad
type thing
um so i mean i you know i really do
think both cases have to be supported
you are right that for certain kinds of
production code um
which you know that you just want the
thing to hair trigger and blow up
but so
yeah maybe it may be helpful to make
this concrete and what we actually think
a specific piece of code could do so in
this example that was described
i mean
i think what you're describing and make
sure i understand this is there's some
implicit thing that's you know based on
the fact that i'm in a notebook that
kind of sets up a handler that causes an
exception within this function
to
be suppressed so that you know this
exception here doesn't run and control
flow kind of i don't i don't even know
what would be returned in this case but
you know this would instead of throwing
a failure this would like result in null
and then my wonderful function would
turn into null or something oh it turned
into failure and the failure would fail
inside
right will be the failure of whatever
was in here or something right that
would be really nice to be able to
switch between those and in some cases
of critical
code you want the thing to just fail but
in other cases you wanted to just leave
a piece of symbolic failure in there
that you can then look at
yeah i think that's a nice that would be
really nice
i so yeah and i think that has merit so
i'm gonna let me illustrate the case i'm
worried about
if i write code like this okay and we'll
pretend this is raised and it's a
failure and i'm in this
non-hair trigger mode maybe it's the
default mode in notebooks right where i
in my code it looks like i can never
reach this case if my condition has not
been satisfied
what you're describing is a way that
code that very explicitly looks like you
know a condition has been checked and
validated and now i can do something
knowing that condition is true could
still run i'm sorry wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute
you're saying
well yes you're right yeah that that
could happen yes
and what if that condition is you know
password validated right
i mean this is you know a problem
exactly like this is what caused the
heart breed ssl bug
that their heart heart bleed sorry it
was a similar kind of you know very
nuanced control flow and code that at
first glance looked completely
reasonable but okay look
this is the whole point we've got a
slider here between
the case of critical code
where nothing can go wrong just blow up
if anything if if you if anything says
boo just exit
versus i mean
yeah for such cases really
you have to expect that
that you wrap that my wonderful function
uh with something that catches the
arrows and turns them into failure
returns failure objects i mean that
suppress or
handle
which cases
well so the ones that that shouldn't
that my wonderful function
for some reason is designed to throw an
exception in some cases but then
suddenly you don't want that
that the exception to come to top level
and so you would have something like
that no but but look no no no no look
it's more complicated than that you have
a big stack of code and you know at the
time when one thing was written somebody
said this is going to be a critical
piece of code but somebody else just
wants to use it as a thing where if it
works great if it doesn't so what and
you sure don't want that that lower
function that said i'm critical just
exit everything you know quit the kernel
if i don't work well it's not it's not
quit the colonel it's stop doing and
actually throw
and go up right and and be handled by
whatever handle look
we keep circling around the same problem
the problem is we can't know exactly
what the programmer wants we are
automating some sort of bucketing of
different kinds of things the programmer
might want
but then you then you use handle to
catch those errors and return something
useful in these cases in which case
well
you say okay so this function
throws so throws an exception but i know
that this exception is not fatal in in
wherever i use the function so i wrap it
in handle i say this exception turns
into
a failure object or dollar null or zero
or whatever
but i mean you have to make your ex
exten
intent clear in some cases you cannot
always
accept expect everything to to just work
automatically in the right way
okay maybe there's also one other one
other anecdote although it's a little
bit different because it doesn't really
involve control flow but you know this
is a little bit like the third argument
of quiet
and as far as i can tell i i've never
seen anyone use the third argument of
quiet i don't think it's much the second
argument i haven't used an argument
okay but to my mind
the thing we're trying to do that
there's two issues one is
the i mean it's trying to implement the
sliding scale
of
you know because there are other cases
where
where things you know one thing i've
wanted to do is to have these messages
that are off by default
like for example there are functions
which return unevaluated
um and they do so without a message
but in fact chances are okay it's really
hard to tell whether
i don't know
um
what's a good example
um
whether whether something is
uh
an error condition are there even worse
cases like for example uh square root of
minus one
okay it could be considered an error
when you get square root of minus one i
mean in a typed language
you know whether where the return type
is supposed to be real that would be an
error
for us it's not generally an error but
one can imagine a you know one could
imagine in a different setup a message
that was off by default
that
would
you know message about that situation
and
where that message
could if appropriate be caught
and in other words we've got all these
things but i'm i don't think it's going
to be the case i mean there are messages
there are situations in which it is very
well defined is it a bad thing is it not
a bad thing in in the case where you can
define things with types that's an
example of a a class of situations in
which
you know oh it's a it's coming back with
the wrong type so it's an error but
that's not the only type of error one
can imagine
you know types are a particular way of
essentially describing
erroring or not erroring
so i mean i'm well
i mean
let me back up a bit and i think what
we're really talking about are
conventions
right we could have the convention that
you know
you
um
you know you in your package
you you handle all of your exceptions
and if you know and you know you return
a failure to top level and then if you
know if you're a user in the notebook or
if you're in a packet if you're some
third-party quote-unquote developer
who's using
the package then you you you know
you check for
failure and re-raise the exception
or we can have the
the
the convention that you know
open open
right doesn't uh
throw a message and return a failure
object if you try to
uh you know if opening a file fails it
you know throws an exception and then
it's the responsibility of the user to
to catch that um
and do what they want with it and that
allows certain kinds of programming but
it also
[Music]
sort of disallows other kinds of
programming like the kind where you just
sort of use my wonderful function and
expect it to
sort of give you a list where things
either succeeded or didn't
yeah
in other words uh the programmer who
uses this code like the one who writes
this map
can't write their code
not being aware of which mechanism is
being used reliably and that's the
problem okay look guys guys i think you
i think the thing i keep on saying is
and we need to wrap for now in a moment
here but but the thing i keep on saying
is
there is
you know one case is you're writing
critical code you want precise behavior
you know
that's one thing i don't i i i and we're
saying that you're just wrong and that
that's not the question at hand okay all
right explain
right
the the ques right in both cases it's a
critical error and the function stops
working the question is the is the way
that my wonderful function behave does
it return
a failure object and then you know the
the
caller
re-raises that if they want to use it in
this exception or does it just roll with
the failure object or does my wonderful
function actually you know raise an
exception that moves outside of it and
you know allow
cross
cross package
you know raising and handling
which in particular would have the
consequence of you know that particular
map unless you wrapped it in a handle
could potentially just
you know end in the middle without
returning anything if there was an
unhand holded exception
i i'm sorry i lost so
to put it in a slightly different way
if we allow exceptions to cross the
boundaries like this
we would have to somehow document that
certain function that is being exposed
can throw an exception
and the user who writes uses that in a
map for instance they'll have to be
aware of that and put handle on top of
that manually
and uh that's horrible
yeah but it's hard to see whether there
is a fully automated solution that
avoids that
okay so the issue is
which functions are capable of returning
a thing
that you you don't want any function
other than handle
to be confronted with something which is
of the wrong structure
that is the thing around map
should assume it's going to return a
list for example even if the contents of
that list might be opaque and might
contain some failure objects and things
like that but you don't want
if possible the structure i mean
obviously the thing that's outside the
map could depend on more details about
what's returned and at some level you
can't
you know you can't determine all of that
but
you know you don't want it to be the
case that the map might just return you
know something completely unmap return
like so to speak
well map
that that that's
well right that's not the case right
if if if if if my wonderful function
you know catches all of its internal
uh exceptions and returns a failure
object then you'll get a list if my
wonderful function
uh and you don't have the handle there
you know if my wonderful function raises
its own exceptions and that handle isn't
there
then you know map will never finish
evaluating
and it'll you know it that exception
will go on either to
an outer handle or
top level and and the evaluation will
end
um if you have a handle like this
explicitly wrapping my wonderful
function
then you'll get a list which will
you know depend on the contents of how
what your failure function does
i guess why isn't this like enclosed
confirm at this level by the time you
that this micro inside
why isn't this effectively confirming
close
yeah this confirm and close
um
[Music]
well it's like in close but
i mean it's just i mean those are in one
level yeah
yeah
okay it's dynamic and it goes more than
one level it's the main
difference here right yeah
whereas enclosed confirmed doesn't have
a convenient way to do non-lexical
stuff
i mean it does but not not in the
default case
two argument form does no i i really do
yeah right um okay i i still want to say
that and we really need to rap here and
we should continue this this is a this
is a good start
i mean i think many of the right issues
are being raised so to speak not to make
a part
um
but
i'm really concerned about this this
point about the fact that
this is providing a reasonable safety
net
for typical programming
by the time we're kind of ratcheting it
up to this is a critical path piece of
code etc etc etc um yes the mechanism
needs to work for that but there's an
awfully high value to just this generic
safety net type stuff and being able to
do things because this thing about you
know is you know somebody might say oh
my gosh you put this message this error
to do with a ill-conditioned matrix you
put it in the wrong bin
that blew me up somehow
and we're never going to be able to
decide it's it's like it's like you know
it was hard enough we've tried to do
this categorizing messages
okay
what counts as a critical thing versus a
just uh oh well it might be wrong but it
isn't necessarily wrong like square root
of minus one for example that's a very
hard thing to define and we're never
going to get it precisely right and i
don't think but i don't think we're
attempting to
do that
is the point
well if all you're doing here is to have
something which is explicit raises and
handles
i don't think that's solving the bigger
problem because the bigger problem is
you've got a system where all kinds of
crazy things can go wrong and depending
on what your use case is you may or may
not care about those
and what i think we need to be doing
is as much as possible to automate what
would okay the default cases nobody's
going to put in any error handling code
at all okay
and for our built-in function built-in
functions we try hard to have good error
handling for things in the function
repository for example we don't worry
too much about error handling
but the thing is can we make an
intermediate case where there is some
level of basically automated error
handling that's pretty good
that maybe segues into the case where
people are doing real sort of tight
programming and want to make sure that
nothing could possibly go wrong
although i claim that nothing could
possibly go wrong
is
you know that's a very hard thing to
define because sometimes if you're too
hair triggery then you'll find that
things where you're like really you know
the thing just errored out in that case
you know i wanted to see the the
thousand results that i would have got
without seeing the thousand and first
one that errored out
i i don't think one can ever completely
win at that but one can choose
on the sliding scale to be more hair
triggery and more kind of you know if
anything goes wrong error out
does this make sense
yeah though i think um i mean i think
one i mean maybe we should should try to
wrap up but i think
i think like you were saying it's a hard
problem to do this categorization and
i'm not sure that we necessarily need to
invent an error handling specific
mechanism to do that i mean you could
imagine like the case you gave right
like this function does doing something
internally on a matrix and you know it
cares about some property of that matrix
i forget exactly what you said
yeah if that's if there are cases where
sometimes you care about that and
sometimes you don't that might be
that might better be represented as an
option value type thing to the function
rather than something that is imposed
implicitly from outside this is the
problem the problem is
the problem is the programmer does not
foresee all the things that can go wrong
okay
and what we're trying to do
is to
bulk catch
certain categories of things
like you know
there are cases that where points might
be collinear we didn't think of that
now is it an error case because then you
know let's say the points are collinear
so we haven't defined a a normal vector
direction
okay
is that a heinous error
or is it just a oh that's an awkward
case i don't know what we should do in
that case you know have it come back
as a pink box and then somebody can go
see why is there a pink box there oh yes
that's that case i better deal with that
case but it's not that critical because
that situation is one where we're never
going to get an answer anyway so who
cares
right it's the the program i cannot
foresee this that's the whole point
that's that's the that's the you know
this is kind of recovery programming not
you know main path programming in the
main path if they know oh i should put
in something that handles the case where
the file is missing great then they know
that they can explicitly do it what
we're trying to do i think is to have
something where it does something not
completely stupid in that case
but you know whether if the programmer
wants to put more protections in they
can go and use the same mechanism to add
more protections and to be more pedantic
but if they're just you know doing it
sloppily
the point is even with comparatively
sloppy programming we want to be able to
get the error handling to be better than
it is now that's my point of view
you know if they want to be pedantic let
them be pedantic if they're not being
pedantic let it provide a decent safety
net where the thing won't just go
completely crazy
yeah so maybe i mean
last example but let's let's suppose you
have code like this
it should be written like this if i'm
being careful i write it like this
um
i presume you mean i'm not in front of
uh yes yes right so if i'm a careful
programmer i write this
and this is what i get what you're
talking about is i'm not a careful
programmer i'm just
yeah just put that in there and then out
outside of that is something that asks
for the string length of the results and
outside of that it does this and you
know you're asking for the string length
and that should fail it shouldn't just
say 17 because that's the unevaluated
code answer or something
um
and you know you just don't want
you know i this is the case this is what
i think we need to think about is is
what
um
you know how to get something not
completely terrible to happen given that
we're dealing with sloppy prototyping
programming
um or we're just dealing with very
complicated code because the thing that
you know after all a big part of our
value proposition is the automation of
lots of kinds of things what we are now
talking about is the automation of error
conditions
yeah
so i want to separate between two cases
though because i think some of the
tension here is
um at least for me
i don't object in theory to the idea
that we could imagine you know some
super handler that's implicitly at the
outer level when you're using notebook
and it has something like this you know
if read sync fails i i get this right
and this i don't mind so much because
flow that just jumps away when something
goes wrong i think is is
defensible like for exactly the reason
you said you want to opt into a little
bit more automated error handling um
what i think is more objectionable i
think is where the tension in this
discussion is coming from is the idea
instead of where we're in this case
right where there's an explicit raise
that gets kind of ignored right
because this
you know if this happens it's kind of
defined by the environment and and you
know it's it's less clear that this just
jumping away is going to have bad
effects from code that doesn't get run
here's code that looks like it should
get run well i know that so this is a
question of right so this is the
question of
right this is this is why this is a
non-trivial piece of design by the time
the user or the programmer is explicitly
putting in things like raise you
probably need to take them more
seriously
yeah right by the time but if they're
not if they're just blindly going
forward and putting in these functions
you probably want to you know you you
just want to provide a safety net
okay we have got to wrap this up um
there was a comment on our live stream
about noting that this will affect the
compiler whatever is done here and yes
that's completely true
um
okay we got to continue this another
time good start guys very good start
let's um